après Emmanuel Macron en interview dans
pyve gadget c'est une info étonnante qui
a fait le buzz tout le week-end Marlène
Schiappa sera en une du magazine Playboy
si beaucoup ont d'abord cru à une blague
le magazine de charme connu notamment
pour ses clichés érotiques après bien
assortis une longue interview de la
secrétaire d'État accompagnée de
quelques photos où elle évoque la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
l'IVG ou encore les droits LGBT mais
tandis que Marlène Schiappa et Gérald
Darmanin ont tenté d'éteindre une
polémique grandissante a fait savoir
qu'elle n'était pas pardon de rentrer
dans ce détail nu de leur côté élément
de la majorité la première ministre mais
aussi de nombreux opposants politiques
ont fustigé la secrétaire d'État
présente en une du magazine alors que
les protestations contre la réforme des
retraites font rage moi j'ai
l'impression d'un écran de fumée entre
sa têtu Pif Gadget je sais pas
maintenant on va avoir un épisode de
Goldorak avec les membres du
gouvernement alors Marlène c'est pas
dans Playboy le propriétaire du magazine
s'exprime ce soir dans TPMP
moi je dis bravo à Jean-Christophe
florentin bravo à vous quel beau quel
coup de gym vraiment bravo à vous voilà
je dis moi quand des mecs font parler
d'eux et qui font ils sont intelligents
et qui font des beaucoup je leur dis
bravo
c'est un beau coup c'est vous qui avez
l'idée oui comment vous avez une idée
parce qu'il faut toujours surprendre
vous c'est le téléspectateur moi c'est
le lecteur exactement et servir des
choses
un contenu attendu passé attendu donc ça
crée pas le buzz ok
c'était parmi les les personnes
auxquelles l'ont de cette conceptant pas
avoir dans Playboy pourtant la plus
Playboy compatible
il faut jamais s'interdire quelque chose
et c'était la plus Playboy compatible
parce que son franc-parler parce que
elle aurait pu se servir ce qu'elle a
fait du magazine pour
exprimer quelques prises de position
féministes pour surprendre ici et puis
parce que parce qu'elle est
plutôt photogénique alors on va voir
quelques photos dans un instant en
parler ensemble tout à l'heure alors
c'est des photos je vous en parler alors
justement parce qu'on va parler avec
Maître Ludo mais ça ça sera après c'est
un petit souci sur ces photos merci
d'être là aussi alors Marlène Schiappa
ça fait énormément parler donc vous le
coup est réussi
on sera au toilettes ou je sais pas où
Amélie je crois que c'est le médecin il
est en train de bouquiner ce gars là
c'est quoi la question mettez-moi la
question toujours derrière on est pas
compliqué pour cette ouverture moi je
dis déjà bravo Jean-Christophe florentin
donc les photos bon on va aller voir
dans un instant voilà c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas ça va oui c'est elle reste
très digne elle ne sert après la
fonction comme certes comme j'ai pu le
le lire l'entendre ici et là bien sûr
elle est pas en drapé toute nue dans un
drapeau français comme j'ai pu le voir
aussi donc voilà elle reste elle ne
salit pas sa fonction elle
est dans des positions dans des tenues
étonnantes certes pour un ministre mais
ça reste tout à fait
[Musique]
il y a un piano
[Rires]
je suis désolé
alors c'est quoi la question oh c'est
quoi la question par contre
c'est un super coup de com et que cette
polémique elle est presque sexiste les
photos elles sont pas choquantes elles
sont pas érotiques c'est des photos
qu'on aurait pu voir dans d'autres
magasins
parce que je me demande je me pose la
question si c'était un ministre qui
avait posé par exemple en une d'un
magazine comme têtu qui met en parfois
en scène des hommes torse nu dénudés et
ce qui aurait la même polémique je ne
pense pas ce qui choque c'est
l'association entre une ministre et un
magazine un peu sexy avec une
réplimination un peu sulfureuse mais en
soi il y a rien de choquant et pour moi
il dépasse pas les limites en faisant ça
et c'est un super coup de com pour vous
et pour elle aussi donc bravo elle je
suis d'accord avec vous à tel point
qu'on a passé deux numéros en arrière à
une interview de Jacques Attali
ça n'a pas fait mais une seule goutte
d'encre
il était très digne aussi
je souscris complètement à ce que est-ce
qu'elle a fait et effectivement quand on
entend enfin moi quand j'entends les
réactions que je trouve puritanes et
totalement hypocrite je me dis que
vraiment je ne savais pas que la police
desmeure ça existait encore en France je
suis très très étonné de des réactions
et je me pose aussi la question si ça
avait été un homme politique un homme et
pas une femme politique est-ce qu'une
femme politique a le droit d'être dans
Playboy ou alors il faut que ce soit que
des femmes nues dans Playboy donc
vraiment moi ça me ça me pose vraiment
la question et par ailleurs où elle doit
aller pour parler de féminisme et ben là
où justement on imagine que les femmes
sont des objets et pas des sujets elle
fait 12 pages où elle dit justement que
la femme est un sujet elle parle de la
femme en Afghanistan elle parle des
droits LGBT elle parle de du féminisme
et donc c'est là où elle doit être
si elle parle au magazine Elle elle
parle à un lectorat qui est déjà
convaincu si elle peut le voir
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps c'est partout et tout le temps en
France les femmes sont libres non
déplaise au rétrograde et aux hypocrites
on parle de vous gilberté
[Rires]
ce qui est grave c'est la réaction du
Premier ministre ah ouais je suis
d'accord euh
qui vient la sermonner au prétexte elle
a pas le droit d'être photographié et
elle peut pas lire je profite de son
corps pardonnez-moi et je mire de son
corps comme elle l'entend
donc
ça démontre quand même à quel point on
en est aujourd'hui
qu'on sera gardé et je me suis imaginé
Marlène Schiappa sous Mitterrand
une femme libérée c'est pas si facile
Madame Cher madame Schiappa à son style
à son style je n'aurais pas posé c'était
inapproprié elle l'a dit écoutez
personne
moi je vous dis que personne n'a vu
cette interview moi je l'ai pas lu cette
interview personne l'a vu donc d'abord
on commande des choses qu'on a pas vu
deuxièmement madame Chapa a fait savoir
qu'elle n'était pas pardon de rentrer
dans ce détail nu dans dans ce magazine
donc écoutez voilà écoutez moi je vais
vous dire je me ferais pas dire man
Chapa qui est une femme politique
courageuse qu'à son caractère qu'à son
style qui n'est pas le mien mais je le
respecte et vous l'avez dit en tous les
cas vous on vous retrouve dans une autre
revue très différente quand même c'est
la Revue des Deux Mondes je voudrais le
souligner parce que dans cette revue
alors c'est vrai que voilà il a défendu
c'est drôle d'ailleurs ce qu'il a déjà
Darmanin c'est vrai que là vous allez
attaquer BFM parce qu'ils ont montré les
photos est-ce que nous on peut les
montrer ou pas parce que Emmanuel Hulot
pour une redire vous allez attaquer BFM
non ce que ce que l'on a attaqué auprès
de l'arcom c'est la méthode utilis ée
par BFM TV pour obtenir ses photos
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait alors
ils m'ont ils m'ont joint en fin de
semaine dernière pour m'inviter sur leur
plateau demain soir
auquel je n'irai pas invitation que
laquelle je ne répondrai pas plus
regardez ici en plus je préfère être
chez vous j'essaie
qui était sur BFM hier je pense qu'il a
pu faire son marché tranquille ce matin
demain ça sera plus compliqué
oui donc BFM avait TV m'avait sollicité
pour venir sur le plateau et présenter
des choses j'aurais dit ok mais comme on
sort jeudi on va décaler un peu le
calendrier à mardi si vous voulez bien
et puis son je ne sais pas par quel
procédé ce sont procurés ils ont volé
ces photos mais en plus ce sont des
mauvais voleurs parce qu'ils n'ont pas
pris les meilleurs et croyez moi quand
vous verrez jeudi il y a des photos qui
sont bien de bien meilleure qualité et
bien plus intéressantes et bien plus
étonnante que celle-là alors non
seulement voleur mais en plus mauvais
vol est-ce qu'on peut les voir nous
celle-là ou pas je les ai pas sur moi je
les ai moi
parce que je les ai volé à BFM
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très bien non c'est dommage je vous
expliquerai pourquoi d'accord pourquoi
parce que il veut pas
que vous qui allez exclusivité qui sort
le jeudi c'est vrai exactement oui mais
c'est pas le même groupe que nous hein
[Rires]
donc il y a une parole à respecter voilà
Paris Match sans jeudi et je voudrais
pas
mal j'adore Paris Match la coupe avec
non mais c'est vrai voilà avec avec
manger des pop-corn
ville
[Rires]
les détracteurs parce qu'on a beaucoup
de oui qui pense que qu'elle a bien fait
Marlène Schiappa moi j'ai pour moi j'ai
pour principe et c'est fou alors c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être qu'on ne va
pas de toujours défendre mes amis quoi
qu'il fasse surtout face à tous les les
loups
et surtout quand ils ont raison
juste un truc dire un truc d'accord le
timing pas le timing je vous dis la
vérité Marlène Schiappa elle est chaque
ministre alors dans ce cas là le
ministre de l'Agriculture il peut rien
faire en ce moment et donc s'il va faire
ici il va au salon de l'agriculture on
va lui dire ouais mais en ce moment tu
devrais pas y aller parce que truc
gadget d'Emmanuel Macron qui a été
beaucoup critiqué également moi je vais
vous dire il peut parler à tout le monde
il a envie de parler à pli gadget non
mais les mecs moi c'est comme les gens
qui critiquent parce qu'il y en a plein
qui sont jaloux vous verrez il y a
quotidien qui a fait un truc là il pas
besoin de ce qu'ils sont jaloux en fait
que Laurent ninez de police viennent
chez nous ce soir donc ils ont fait oui
n'importe quoi le préfet non mais il
préfet il veut parler au plus gros
nombre de gens on veut parler à toute la
France forcément pour s'expliquer et
pour expliquer ce qui se passe sur les
manifs actuellement voilà donc forcément
il a choisi TPMP et c'est très bien pour
nous qui viennent ce soir je vais vous
dire moi le sectarisme et les gens qui
disent il faut aller là il faut faire si
il faut faire ça il faut écouter telle
musique il faut voter telle personne il
faut regarder telle émission de télé les
Français ils savent très bien ce qu'il
doit faire ça sert à rien de leur dire
vous avez le droit de faire ça vous
pouvez faire si vous pouvez faire ça
regardez-nous tous les journalistes dis
il faut pas regarder peut-être même plus
ils disent ça plus les audience monte
donc vous voyez bien que les Français
ils n'écoutent surtout pas les
journalistes
sur les il y a une telle défiance au
sein des Français contre les
journalistes et je suis pas ça oui voilà
on le sait que les journalistes et les
Français moi dès que les Français
marrent dans la rue ils me disent Cyril
on croit plus les journalistes tu
regardes TPMP parce que c'est les vrais
infos nous on va revenir là-dessus dans
un instant il y avait sur les quatre
mecs qui sont venus vendredi les quatre
flics il y a quand même plein de qui ont
écrit il y avait pas un flic dedans on a
fait toutes les vérifications on a les
cartes de police les gars donc vous
savez mieux que nous il y avait bien
quatre policiers qui étaient avec nous
vendredi soir donc pour vous dire ils
nous disent que des conneries donc voilà
donc et je vois que les gens le savent
donc là sur Marlène Schiappa aussi on
doit pas il faut arrêter de dire tout ce
qu'on doit faire et tout ce qu'on doit
pas faire ça c'est insupportable oui
géraline non mais c'est pour ça et
Valérie il a dit c'est pour ça que ça
ressemble à mort à Marlène Schiappa
cette ouverture elle va toujours là où
on l'attend pas là où elle est pas la
bienvenue elle va pas elle a réunion
elle vient ici pour parler avec vous et
au gilets jaunes tout le monde dit mais
mon dieu mais quel abomination mais
pourquoi elle fait ça elle va aux
universités d'été de la France insoumise
alors qu'elle peut se faire huer c'est
pas grave elle y va parce que c'est
comme ça qu'elle est elle va la
convention des droites avec Zemmour et
avec Marion avec Marion Maréchal-Le Pen
elle va elle va pas un truc entre amis
voilà et elle est toujours comme ça et
moi je trouve que c'est ça qui est fort
justement dans le cas et ensuite sur le
côté pare-feu genre le timing c'est pas
le bon timing et déjà quel naïveté parce
que avril méchant ça veut dire que les
trimestrielles c'est pas fait le jour
même vous la verra
ce serait pas paru il y a deux mois où
ça paraîtrait dans deux mois il y aurait
la même polémique autour et cetera là tu
l'as tout le monde et à l'international
c'est un gros succès
qu'il a également défendu qui a défendu
la secrétaire d'État après géraldman
Darmanin c'est pré-casse des venait
aussi qu'il a défendu puis bien sûr il y
a Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a été énervé on
verra la vidéo de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
après voilà le pote de Gilles Verdez
Jean-Luc il était énervé à mon avis je
vais l'abonner à Playboy ça va le calmer
allez au revoir c'est parti Prisca
d'abord sur Playboy je dois le dire
est-ce que Marlène Schiappa est connue
pour avancer pour mettre la lumière sur
les enjeux liés au corps des femmes
liées au droit des femmes je crois que
oui est-ce que le magazine Playboy est
connu pour promouvoir le sujet du droit
des femmes et le rapport des Francs je
crois que non donc il est important que
nous puissions aussi adresser des sujets
dans ce magazine il ne s'agit pas de
poser nu mais d'aborder des sujets
importants qui aujourd'hui sont toujours
là présent alors justement est-ce
qu'elle pose du Marlène Schiappa non
évidemment non elle reste
sexy
je sais pas je me souviens plus très
bien mais on n'en voit plus sur les
plages l'été que
non faut pas oublier ce qu'elle dit
aussi ça c'est important et surtout
ça c'est oui mais mettre on le sait vous
avez raison c'est pour ça qu'on est sexy
comme les collants
[Musique]
quoi elle est quoi alors
les
super digne il n'est pas toujours dans
le drapeau elle est elle est l'étonnante
elle est sexy elle est jolie elle pose
bien le prends bien la lumière
c'est une très jolie ministre d'accord
alors gilberté tu es pas content non
vous avez utilisé le mot timing le
timing et dévastateur c'est pas moi qui
dit c'est Elisabeth oui mais le timing
est dévastateur je suis d'accord par
rapport à l'IVG par rapport à quoi le
timing
donc le timide ne va pas parce que en
fait le timing moi le propos qui est
très intéressant je n'en doute pas c'est
lutte ces combats mais la vue la crise
sociale vu l'ampleur de la contestation
vu ce qui se passe en France c'est
inaudible et l'association des photos et
du côté sulfureux de Playboy alors
encore une fois vous avez évolué etc
j'entends bien mais néanmo moi j'ai vu
le magazine il y a rien c'est devenu un
magazine intello
j'ai rien compris c'est ce que vous
voulez je comprends tout à fait mais
néanmoins pour moi c'était pas le bon
moment et à fortiori si comme le dit
Madame borne elle ne lui a pas donné son
autorisation si Marlène Chapat n'a pas
demandé l'autorisation à Madame borne là
je trouve que c'est compliqué les
animaux
d'avoir une autorisation pour se faire
photographe vous savez très bien vous
savez très bien est-ce qu'il vous permet
est-ce qu'il faut nous dire au Premier
ministre à chaque fois oui madame borne
madame borne valide les interviews et
les prises de parole bien sûr
et je pense qu'à la forme bien fait de
de s'affranchir de tout ça alors
pourquoi madame borne conteste alors
il y a des gens qui sont contre aussi
ils sont comme vous Daniel alors moi
c'est le timing oui il est pas très bon
mais c'est pas très grave mais c'est je
vais je vais faire ma vieille Rayak mais
pour moi Playboy c'est un magazine de
femme qui pose nue pour attiser le le
désir des hommes ça reste enfin
excusez-moi j'ai vu quelques images
quelques photos il y a des corps où on
ne voit même pas le visage de la femme
donc pour moi ça reste quand même le
symbole de la femme objet si si j'ai vu
j'ai vu que des fesses ou que des bah ou
alors c'est pas c'est ce que tu
regardais
et donc en fait ce que je veux dire
c'est que pourquoi pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est pour qu'elle fasse ce genre de
chose c'est vrai que c'est une rebelle
elle est en avance elle est donc elle
est dans son bol mais
parce qu'elle est belle parce qu'elle
est intelligente c'est que c'est moi
pour moi pour moi c'est en contradiction
avec
des amis des années pour moi le support
n'est pas bon
de le donner dans l'idée que je m'en
fais et je pense que beaucoup s'en font
et c'est pour ça on a peut-être trop tôt
du monde avec Coca-Cola et Apple mais
c'est vrai qu'on a un petit peu
prisonnier aussi d'une réputation mais
le support n'a plus rien à voir avec ce
qu'il était il y a 5 ans ce n'est plus
un journal de Fès toujours
Jean-Christophe juste c'est vous qui
l'avez appelé oui vous avez dit quoi
j'ai dit bonjour je dirige Playboy
est-ce que vous seriez ok pour faire un
sujet chez nous et la couverture
Marlène Chapa je n'ai pas eu tout de
suite j'ai d'abord eu ses conseillers et
vous en dit quoi qui m'ont dit
qui m'ont dit pourquoi pas nous allons
en parler laissez-nous envoyez-nous un
mail d'accord j'ai envoyé un mail sans y
croire plus que ça et puis
m'a répondu très rapidement après s'en
est suivi des quelques communications
téléphoniques des rendez-vous on a mis
au point le le scénario de ce qu'on a
des photographiés les questions qu'on a
déposées et puis on a réalisé tout ça il
y a un premier rendez-vous qui a été
raté pour cause d'emploi du temps de la
ministre normalement tout cela devait
être shooté il y a un mois et demi et en
fait cet été il y a 15 jours donc en
termes de calendrier on n'est pas non
plus tous mettre du calendrier et on est
sorti parce qu'un trimestriel sort tous
les trois mois donc notre déplaise à
Madame board nous sommes sortis au
moment de devions sortir alors elle est
elle était contente du rendu ou pas elle
a tout validé elle a tout valide elle a
tout vu
mais la même rajouter certains propos à
son interview d'accord les questions
j'aurais dû lui poser que j'ai oublié de
lui poser
et elle a tout elle assume tout et je
trouve ça très courageux alors il y a
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il n'est pas content
il a pas l'argent il était d'accord pour
aller dans
playboys
encore envoyé un sms tout à l'heure on
attend ta réponse ainsi que ah non sans
déconner
[Rires]
dans un conflit social
le plus grand qu'on ait vu de l'histoire
de ce pays depuis 50 ans et il lance
comme ça toutes sortes de petits
trucs de diversion alors monsieur dusoft
vient dire que dire qu'il est homosexuel
donc bon très bien tout le monde s'en
fout elle elle va dans ce journal
et c'est une provoque pour que vous me
posiez la question moi j'ai pas envie de
perdre mon temps avec elle on le
président de la République va dans Pif
alors je suppose qu'il doit y avoir Pif
Gadget cette semaine avec une petite
matraque ou une grenade lacrymogène
enfin tout ça c'est une sorte de
distraction par rapport au sujet central
alors attends parce que là j'ai vu c'est
alors non mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc
c'est quoi l'histoire parce que c'est
vrai qu'il a failli faire ah oui il a
failli faire l'été dernier de faire une
interview de Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
dernier moment il nous a planté et c'est
sur normalement parti remise j'ai encore
envoyé un sms cet après-midi Jean-Luc
j'attends ta réponse
bien sûr là on est un peu d'illustration
bah bien sûr l'hypocrisie elle a raison
plein dedans c'est comme Marlène Chapa
elle est venue ici la première après
tout le monde a voulu faire et tout le
monde bien sûr oui Castaldi parce que
juste ça fait juste c'est pour tout
juste pour la pour le cacher il faut
bien que parler
juste pour toutes les raisons que tu as
évoqué alors il fait une interview dans
Elle ou dans le monde personne on aurait
parlé donc elle a pris effectivement un
média dont a été certaine il y aura un
vrai écho donc c'est parfaitement réussi
que n'importe quel autre magasin donc
c'est très bien joué sur mon sentiment
merci c'est bien résumé pour résumer en
fait
68 % donc 32 % oui je savais pas je
croyais pas qu'il allait avoir autant de
bruit
68 % de Macron et on associe du coup
là ça part là c'est voilà puis bon lui
je crois qu'il a fait lui il a il a il
vous avez fait le boulot je pense que
les gens vous ont kiffé